and we are right now joined by the
genius and game player magnus carlsen
winner of semi-final
first match congratulations magnus thank
you
so what's your reaction to this last
game another roller coaster with you
winning i mean that's what we saw and uh
a blunder by you and then winning again
uh yeah you're not really supposed to
miss mates in truth i think at this
level
so that was uh
yeah that was really crazy um
apart from from from that i'd actually
also
missed um that he could uh
he could play rook a7 there later on um
defending his h-pawn because if i'd seen
that i never would have gone for it um
but it's very typical like
i i feel like there should be something
in the position and then
i realize it like right after i made my
move i
see see how i could have uh how i could
have won
and that point yeah i thought
this game was gonna was gonna be a draw
and i still have a
difficult task in the in the last game
uh but
yeah fortunately um
it um all uh yeah it all came apart from
him
uh for him at the end still it it was
never
a very easy draw but i guess one that he
he should generally make well a minus
after being very disappointed with your
own play yesterday how are you feeling
with your performance today and the way
you play these games uh
yeah today was a lot better obviously
i think neither of us played
played perfectly especially in the
second game
um where i i also there i missed
uh missed some things but fortunately it
was not not too bad
um but yeah in general i have to be
have to be happy manage to win a model
game the
in the first one and then i think apart
from that blunder the last game also so
it was also fairly decent minus we did
see the
the queens come off very early in both
of your white games
today what was the thought behi behind
those tactics had it anything to do with
sort of the games that yesterday against
daniel dubo
um yeah i think in general um
it's okay for me but uh i guess in the
first game uh
it just happened like that from the
opening but
yeah in in the third game it was
definitely a conscious decision i
thought
um we'd more or less get out of theory
and just get a
queen queenless middle game which i
thought would uh would suit me
fairly well and magnus in the third game
i mean you're already a point up in the
match today and we saw you sacrifice a
rook for a bishop
in i mean amazing circumstances does it
take courage to play those kind of moves
to take a little bit of risk
uh when you're already off in the match
no
not that kind of sacrifice
what is that about then hey yeah i feel
like
that's one of the uh one of the least
courageous
uh sacrifices i've ever i've ever made
um basically yes i do lose
uh rook for um for a bishop that i have
a very strong pawn for it and um
a bishop pair uh as well as wonderful
centralization so it's clear that i'm
not running
any risk other than uh you know
accidental
uh blunders so magnus
um we have seen in the meltwater
champions chess tour so far
it is almost day two in the knockout
stages that you have struggled a little
bit so
how will you avoid that tomorrow i don't
know
sorry for reminding you we'll
we'll see uh right now i'm just
happy with um having played um
a day of burger chess well we
congratulate you on that
magnus and good luck on day two tomorrow
thank you